this is an 8 news now breaking news  alert  we're getting updates on a homicide  investigation near decatur and gown mary  jane belleza is live at the scene with  more mary jane  [Music]  hi good afternoon bianca we are here in  the north las vegas area on the 5100  block of cudi road at this time you can  already see police tape blocking off the  residential area and police right now  having a heavy police presence right by  that neighborhood for now we are waiting  to hear more details a news conference  briefing is expected at 12 45 so we are  standing by for the latest details again  this area is blocked off for now heavy  police presence here on cuddy way on the  5100 block this is located in the north  las vegas area now stay with us here on  channel 8 as we will be standing by for  this news conference and we'll make sure  to bring you the latest details on air  and online reporting live here in north  las vegas on 5100 of the cutting block  way mary jane valeza live local now